vegas is a city surrounded by amazing
experiences
and here is one the entire family can
enjoy
[Music]
many of you have been to red rock but
today we're going to show you a side
that you haven't seen before and we're
doing it
with pink jeep tours
[Music]
we've got jerry with pink jeep tours
with us once again it's good to see you
buddy what kind of tours do you guys
offer
we do two types of tours up here at red
rock the first one is a red rock classic
which we do in our tour trekkers we'll
begin at the
visitor center then we hit the loop and
we make several stops along the way
our second one is the rocky gap
adventure which we do in the open air
jeeps
and we get to go off-roading a little
off-roading action now someone's
watching where does the pickup happen
how do you guys pick up all your
customers
we'll pick up at just about every hotel
local and on the strip talk about a
perfect way to spend your afternoon
with this as your backdrop open air jeep
it's a beautiful day as we're moving
along we'll talk
different subjects we'll we'll tell
people about the desert
yeah give us a little fun fact about the
desert well
we're in the mojave desert it's a native
american word it means by the water
that water has is and will be the
colorado river
can people bring a lunch and bring a
lunch with them on the trip
yes they can you can bring food uh we'll
supply all the water they'll need
here's a little red rock fun fact for
you this point right here is the highest
point in the loop
4 800 feet and the views
they're stunning
before we go off-roading i wanted you
guys to meet carol she's with pink jeep
tours
and you're the pilot of the trekker what
are some of the tours that you do
oh we go to we do red rock classic death
valley
hoover dam grand canyon west grand
canyon south and it's such a comfortable
ride tell us about some of the features
we sit inside this thing it's pretty
incredible it's an awesome truck it's a
dodge 3500 pickup truck
we can see 10 passengers we have it's
air-conditioned
the the seats are leer jet seats and
you're sitting up high big gorgeous
beautiful windows
now carol is very knowledgeable so i'm
going to throw a very hard question your
way
a question i don't know the answer to
maybe you do i've been in las vegas
since 1995.
why are the rocks red iron oxide
now we're off road and jerry what's
what's the name of this road
this is rocky gap road we'll go a couple
of miles on here and
get out for a little bit look at some of
the vegetation
[Music]
what a perfect day gorgeous views there
is actually so much to do
in the las vegas territory check out
additional experiences
such as photo tours vegas where you can
explore the city with a professional
photographer
or take a ride with u.s bike travel for
las vegas guided motorcycle tours
all right see what's open beyond the
neon for more visit explore.las vegas
territory.com
and las vegas now we'll be